so
good morning good afternoon good evening
judging by the chat responses it looks
like we have a
very diverse crowd from all parts of the
world which is great so
thank you for joining uh the title of my
talk today is moving the needle
toward organizational success and i'll
include
uh just a general framework for decision
making
i think it applies in multiple areas not
only in sports but also in business
and then i also just want to make note
uh if you can please
uh go to this link this slido link
which there will be a question here uh
we have a
dice game that we're gonna roll through
so please make sure
make use of that as we get going here
so just a few disclaimers as i get
started uh the
the field of sports analytics is an
extremely broad diverse field
uh the 15 to 20 minutes today that i'm
gonna talk is going to be a heavy bias
toward american football
trying to cover the entire field of
sports analytics in 15 to 20 minutes
just isn't possible but
ideally the takeaway you know that i
hope for you is that you're able to take
something away from this that's a it's a
pragmatic solution to solving difficult
problems whether that's in sports
business
or just general life when you're forced
to you know make a difficult decision
that
you know one general framework that you
can apply uh to making that decision and
then obviously using data to help inform
that
so i i had to include this in here at
the beginning so for those of you that
are familiar with the with the
the movie this is from moneyball uh it's
jonah hill's character
and if i had a dollar for every time
someone had asked me so you're like the
guy in moneyball
i'd probably be retired somewhere on a
beach by now but uh
in terms of the reason i want to include
this is that there's a couple of
different
i think misnomers about moneyball what
it is what it isn't so i'm going to
throw my two cents in here
uh in my mind if you approach moneyball
uh as a general philosophy to using data
to help inform decision making
i think that's a really good definition
if you if you limit moneyball
to just player acquisition uh player
selection i think that's a more narrow
focus and i'm going to get to a couple
different
concepts here throughout my talk but
just wanted to make note of that because
i think
quite often sports analytics the the
first term that everyone throws out is
moneyball
and while player acquisition is and how
you acquire players using data is
certainly a piece
of sports analytics it's not it's not
everything so
again hopefully we'll get to that here
in a little bit and i'll be able to
demonstrate that in more detail
okay so if you if everyone can please
take a look at that slido we're gonna
we're gonna roll some dice here so
there's a uh this is a shiny application
and this is publicly available you can
go out to this uh this site
and what we're going to do is i'm going
to go over the rules here just briefly
and once i cover the rules what i'd ask
you to do is please go to that slido
site
again this is part of the the challenge
of doing something on zoom compared to
doing it in person but if you can go to
the slido site
and please vote whether or not yes you'd
want to play this game
no you don't want to play this game and
that last response
as i'm looking at this other slide or
this other screen here is
i'm not sure i didn't think i was going
to have to calculate anything here
today so i'm gonna go ahead and enter
the names and then i'll so i'm gonna be
player one for this game
and rachel didn't know it but she's
gonna be player two
all right so here's here here's the
concept we're going to roll
we're going to simulate a dice roll of
two uh two dice
and then we're going to take the sum of
those two dice uh when you
when you take the sum of those nothing
earth shattering here it's going to be
it's going to yield a sum between 2 and
12 but there's going to be associated
payouts
with the results of those dice rolls so
the way this game is currently
constructed if you see here
is that my winning numbers are eight or
less so any time that the sum of the two
dice is eight or less
rachel's gonna owe me 45 okay
now on the flip side of it the second
component is that if the sum of the dice
is nine or more i'm gonna have to pay
rachel 108
so there's a you're looking at it now
there's a pretty sizable
uh difference in the payouts but there's
also a difference in terms of the
winning numbers so
uh just based on that so if you can just
take 20 seconds or so
and i'll get rolling on this please go
to the slido and vote
yes i'd play this no i wouldn't play
this or i don't want to calculate
anything right now so i'm going to take
the default answer is not true and i'll
i'll monitor the results here mitch i
think you might just need to tell me
when to end the poll and then you'll see
okay
result okay
let's see so far we have 49 50 people
that have
done it so just let me know when you
want me to yep i'll give everybody a few
more seconds here
um for anyone who hasn't seen the slider
yet
the short link to it is rstd
dot io sport
and i'll copy that again in the chat
yeah rachel why don't we go ahead and
stop it there i think it's
we got a pretty good sample there so
looks like most people are saying yes
they would play this uh a few folks are
saying no and then
there's a handful of folks also that are
saying they're not sure so that that's
all fair so
let's go ahead and roll this and i'll
demonstrate uh what's going on here
so as you can see we just selected one
roll to simulate
and the what we're going to focus on is
the results here this
rolls detail section so dice one was a
two dice two is a six
the sum of that's eight so i win forty
five dollars and this is randomly
generated
so i'm just going to continue to click
roll em and you'll see that there are
some variants here
those numbers are updating there you can
see that rachel won that role
with a sum of nine
so as i'm doing this we can do this at
one roll at a time well
i don't want to play one roll at a time
i want to do this multiple times
so let's bump this up to 100 and roll
this
okay now obviously the payouts are
getting a little bit bigger i just won
a little over three thousand but i had
to pay rachel 2700 so
net difference is 675. so now as i'm
starting to increase
the number of roles to simulate what i'd
ask you to focus on is this
this section in here the summary results
again there's variance i'm winning a
little
bit i'm winning a lot okay
and again this is publicly available you
can go to this site and experiment with
it but i'm just going to go ahead and
bump this up to 10 000
and let this run
okay so when i ran this ten thousand
times so we just simulated ten thousand
dice rolls and to show that there's ten
thousand in here
this is the summary this is the tail of
that uh
that data set that was just generated so
the last you can see that rachel
actually won the last
roll and again you can export this data
copy it you can
um look at it more detail on your own
but the more times we play this the more
i'm winning
hopefully that's the takeaway here
another takeaway is that there's
certainly variance that's associated
so let's go ahead and deconstruct what's
going on here
and for those of you that said yes
hopefully you said you wanted to play as
player one and not as player two
and for those of you that said no
hopefully you were looking at it from
player two and not
uh player one
so the general framework for this game
and just in general
that i like to apply is that expected
value is equal to the sum
of the probabilities and the payouts and
some of you that are in academia might
be looking
at saying hey wait a second there's this
great summation notation that
highlights exactly that exactly what i
just said and i would agree
uh i put this on here in this context
for two reasons one
is that as a as an undergraduate math
major that i reached a certain point i
think
through my undergraduate classes where i
was writing proofs and i said you know
what if i have to put some sort of
formula
i'm going to try to deconstruct it into
simpler terms so that's one reason why
this is on here
the second reason i put this on here in
this context is just the sum of the
probabilities and the payouts
is that when you're presenting sometimes
to non-technical
audiences whether that's a coach an
executive someone in your business
i think sometimes the notation can be a
little off-putting so being able to
deconstruct that into simpler terms
i think is one technique or one strategy
i would recommend for your organizations
okay so why this works
by the way has everyone seen this red
okay there it's gone i think somebody
was taking a note possibly
so what we're looking at is this is the
this is the
uh the outcome uh of possibilities
essentially so
dice 1 is on the x there's on the
horizontal axis
dice 2 is on the is on the y and this is
these are the way that the the sum could
possibly turn up right so there's 36
different squares here
and you know you see seven across the
diagonal
and so forth so when we add the players
you can see the advantage the advantage
is certainly to player one
player one has more numbers so there's
26 out of the 36 squares that
that's where the advantages to player
one but recall that player two has a
much higher payout
so player two has fewer squares winning
squares
but there's a much higher payout that's
associated with player two
so again going back to that calculation
of why this works
why expected value so when you go
through the math again it's the sum of
the probabilities
multiplied by the payouts or the
outcomes so again this is
this calculation this entire calculation
is from the perspective of player one
so we're looking at this from player
one's perspective okay so for player one
again 26 out of 36 with a payout of 45
dollars
and there's a key point here that i
wanted to highlight is that for player
again looking at this from player one's
perspective player two
wins ten out of the 36 times and there's
a negative payout associated for player
one when player two wins
that's where that negative comes in okay
then when you do the math
you get to this bottom line and this is
the this is the key takeaway is the way
the game was constructed it was not
rigged
from a uh variation standpoint those are
those were random dice rolls
just using sample within r but the way
that the game was constructed was
it was rigged for player one player one
every time that the dice
those dice were rolled player one had a
two dollar and fifty cent advantage
so from player one's perspective if
somebody offered me that game
and we could play that all day i would
play that game
happily all day every day because i know
that the more times i roll those dice
the more times i'm gonna win okay so
that's there's a couple of things
there's one is that there's a small
advantage and that's going to equate to
a significant gain
in the long run another piece is that
there's variation
you got to be able to withstand the
losses and i'm going to get to that here
in a few moments
but there is certainly variation it
happens they were the way that i had to
construct that i was winning
overall but rachel certainly won her
share as well
so i'm seven slides in and you might be
wondering this guy hasn't said anything
about sports yet when is that
when's that gonna happen so that's where
this uh so now we've reached that point
so i wanted to set that framework
because it's an extremely important
framework
that applies to multiple decision making
processes within the within a front
office within a coaching staff
within a sports performance staff within
a
contract and labor perspective but
ultimately it comes down to
when probability so if you're familiar
with wind probability
multiple media sites have different
variations of this this is that both of
these are screen
from the super bowl last year uh the one
on the left
is from espn and the one on the right is
from number fire
i also want to mention some of the work
that's done in the public
sphere uh with uh i believe lee sharp on
twitter has
a version of this as well and those are
animated so these anymore these
these appear in different formats but
the key takeaway from this is that
what these lines represent is that at
every point in the game it represents
the likelihood that the team
that's on offense or the team that
possesses the ball is going to win
so there's variation you know you see
these uh
these things move a little bit and then
if you recall the super bowl from last
year
tampa bay ended up dominating the game
which is why the last
two quarters or quarter and a half that
their one probability was close to 100
the entire time
and again these these uh graphs appear
in different formats sometimes it's a
single line sometimes it's multiple
lines
sometimes it's flagged by key events and
where those occurred in the game
sometimes there's there's
a time component so again on the just to
clarify this this is value on the y
and it's time on the x
okay so why when probability why why is
this such an important piece
because ultimately when probability is
what you're trying to maximize
but you're trying to add value with win
probability
so i'm going to talk a little bit
there's a i have a couple links on the
next slide there's no shortage of
information about fourth down decision
making
if you're familiar with the football
analytics american football analytics
space there's no shortage of information
available on fourth down but i wanted to
take a slightly different approach here
and i wanted to talk a little bit about
challenges so again if you're not
familiar with the game the short version
of the summary of what you're seeing in
this
gif is the head coach from an nfl team
carries around a red flag in their back
pocket and essentially
they have two opportunities a game to be
able to challenge a ruling on the field
and i'll go ahead and open this link and
once we post these slides you'll be able
to access this on your own so there's a
site
that the nfl maintains and you can
actually test yourself and whether or
not you would
you would challenge that ruling
so again you have two opportunities to
do that throughout the course of the
game
and the way that i approached it when i
was working for teams was
from an expected value standpoint
there's going to be a net change in wind
probability based on the decision
but there's also a probability
associated with the likelihood of the
reversal
so again using our our context for
expected value it's the sum of the
probabilities and the payouts
and this is the this is kind of the uh
the summary
takeaway here is that when there's
there's essentially two different
outcomes that can happen
when you challenge it can either be
reversed or it stays the same
and that's it so if it's reversed
ideally if you're challenging it it's
going to be a positive change in one
probability of a reversal
so that's the first part of this
equation down here on the bottom of the
bottom of the slide it's that reversal
rate what the perceived what that
reversal rate
is multiplied by the positive change in
one probability of a reversal
the second part of it from the expected
value standpoint
is going to be one minus the reversal
rate multiplied by that negative change
in wind probability so there is a catch
you can't there is a penalty associated
with challenging
unsuccessfully if you challenge a play
you lose a timeout
so at various points of the game that
time out
takes on very different meaning and that
was one of the first questions that i
was asked when i first started working
for teams is what's the value of a
timeout
and i thought it was a really
interesting question because there's a
lot of different ways to answer that
question
and based upon where you are in the game
and this can be a conversation for
another day
but where you are in the game certainly
makes a difference
now ideally the way that i tried to
approach this was i really tried to
focus
on this first part of this is that
again in a perfect world what what you
just saw was clearly wrong on the field
and the advice the the advice or the
recommendation down to the coaches on
the field is
challenging there's a high likelihood
that it's going to be reversed
so ideally this is close to one and
ideally this positive change and win
probability of a reversal
is high so where does that where does
that come into play that comes into play
with high leverage situations and if you
going back to these slides previously
when probability at the end of a game
can fluctuate significantly
based upon the plays and what's
happening so when you're in high
leverage situations
ideally this is close to one and this is
a huge swing and win probability it
doesn't always turn out that way
but when you're trying to maximize
decisions and trying to make positive
expected value
bets essentially that's that's kind of
the perfect context there
and again well we have time for q a so i
can i'm more than happy to answer more
questions there
about the challenge process
some additional applications again it
wouldn't be a presentation on football
analytics without mentioning some of the
fourth down work that's
uh publicly available uh there's some
really good work uh
historically from brian burke ben
baldwin recently did an updated version
of this
from the athletic and then the league
office also
posted a video after the playoffs
talking about the importance of fourth
down decisions
and as you go through these links i
would encourage you to go through them
again this is
an overview of sports analytics is i
would encourage you to go through those
and look at how they're
uh they're using similar frameworks for
decision making
and it's essentially expected value
based on the the outcomes and the
results associated with those outcomes
now there certainly are other
applications to my point earlier about
moneyball not being the end-all be-all
there are other applications
and i'll run through these relatively
quickly again a lot of these could be
their own presentations
but from the personnel standpoint
personnel staffs are responsible
are responsible excuse me for player
acquisition so in an nfl front office
that can be either on the college side
or on the pro side with professional
baseball teams it's often referred to as
amateur scouting
this this side of the the personnel
department player performance is another
extremely important piece and with all
the tracking technology that's available
not only for practice but also for games
and it's common this is also commonly
referred to as sports science
or load management load management is
certainly the
term in the mba that you've heard
publicly
and then the last part last major area
is cap and labor and that's
how you value contracts there's a lot of
different ways to
value a contract and again these are all
applications where that expected value
framework
can help your organization make uh
positive gains in the long run
as i wrap up here i just want to mention
a couple lessons learned
from this exercise that really this is a
summary not only from the exercise
uh the shiny application uh but just in
general i'm trying to uh
when i was putting this presentation
together i wanted to try to anticipate
what some of the questions might be
and hopefully this uh captures some of
the potential questions
again i'm happy to answer more of these
as we get to the q and a section
but the first one is consider framing
your decisions as bets
and if if you're not framing your
decisions as bets and you're just
slipping looking at it at a
deterministic level i would highly
encourage you to look at
your decision making from a
probabilistic mindset there
even something that may be perceived as
a hundred percent
uh whether it's a reversal rate it's a
player selection
it's a coaching decision it's a contract
decision
uh i would argue that things that are
100 percent there is
other things can happen and they do
happen so that's why i would highly
encourage a probabilistic mindset
another key piece here is that small
advantages can equate to significant
gains in the long run
and hopefully that was illustrated or
highlighted in the short demonstration
with the with the dice rolling small
advantages when you do that
over multiple uh over longer time
horizons and you do that
at length those equate to significant
gains i've already touched on this luck
and variance piece it's real it happens
things happen in sports players slip
somebody falls down everything else
could go right on the play but somebody
slips
it's bad luck it happens but on the flip
side the ball can also bounce
your way and then the last piece is
extremely important it's valuing the
process
and placing a greater emphasis on the
process rather than the outcomes
it's a really difficult thing to do
especially when you're talking about a
16 and now 17 game season
for nfl teams it's an extremely
difficult thing to do because there is
such a limited
number of games but if you value the
process and understand
that luck is going to happen but you
place an emphasis on the process
and you can live with uh when you're
making best decisions that are
maximizing expected value then that's a
in my mind that's a really good
framework for operating
i'm sure there's a number of people on
this call that they're attending
that maybe you're unfamiliar with sports
analytics want to do something
so here are just some general
recommendations on how to get started
one is first and foremost is go do
something that's a question that
whenever i was asked by students
one of the my first questions would be
what have you done lately
if you're not familiar with the big data
bowl i would highly encourage you to go
look at this information
credit to mike lopez at the nfl league
office for starting this and continuing
to push this forward
the the volume of data has changed
significantly in recent years for the
nfl because of player tracking data
and again i would encourage you to go
get your hands on this data and
experiment with it
uh second piece is approaching subject
matter experts with humility
uh if you many of you on this call may
have advanced
degrees master's degrees in statistics
phds and
uh engineering operations research
whatever your field
or discipline may be if you're going to
get into sports analytics
just one general piece of recommendation
that i have is to approach subject
matter
experts with humility many coaches and
executives may not have
formal phds but they've been around the
game so long that they have what i like
to call the equivalent of phds in their
respective domains
and that before you put something in
front of someone and essentially ask
them to completely change
their philosophy because of a research
study that you did i think it takes a
certain level of humility to be able to
approach those decisions or those
conversations that way
last two pieces here certainly related
to the items above
is if you can't clearly explain your
work excuse me don't expect somebody to
buy in and use it
if it's not transparent what's going on
with your analysis it's very difficult
for people who maybe are non-technical
to be able to understand it and actually
buy in and use it
so place a huge emphasis on being able
to explain your work
and then the last piece is that continue
attending events like today everybody
started from scratch at some point
whether you're just getting started as
an undergraduate you're continuing
you're thinking about a career change
i would highly encourage you to continue
attending events like today and then
last piece here as i wrap
up uh if you're interested in more
contact information you can
contact me on twitter i will say that
i've been under cloak and dagger for a
few years working for teams
so my twitter activity has been
extremely limited i think i have
two tweets to my name at this point so i
anticipate that changing
here in the future but you can contact
me on twitter at mitch taney
these slides will be posted on github at
mitch taney and then you can also
contact me over email these two
different email addresses
and with that rachel i will turn it back
over to you
awesome thank you so much mitch um there
are a few questions on the slido and i'm
noticing a few questions coming into the
chat
too so just so i don't miss any
questions in the chat if you don't mind
putting them on slido
that would be really helpful but mitch
if
a few questions for you from the slido
one from chris is do you recommend any
data sets that detail when a timeout
challenge was used throughout a given
game
for example we can know the score at the
time of challenge
yeah if any date if you're looking for
public data sets uh
the group at carnegie mellon i want to
give them credit uh a few years ago
uh start an nfl scraper and then that's
now turned into nfl
faster i believe i'm saying that right
so it's nfl fastr
it's a public that's an r package it's
on crayon i believe it's on crayon
uh you can go grab that and there's it's
play by play
data uh i see someone there confirming
that so yeah it is on grand so you can
go
grab uh public uh you can go grab nfl
play-by-play data and that includes
win probability expected points and a
host of other things so
again go check out that package if
you're not familiar with it
you can't get your hands on data
directly from the league and then
another data source to go look at if you
really want to test
your analytic analytical skills and uh
just general framework for approaching
large data sets is go use the
big data bull data so it's player
tracking data that's available
for players i can't remember how many
weeks are available on that data set but
that's movement data for all 22 players
on the field if i'm not mistaken
and it's it's a sizable data set
great thank you one of the actual most
uploaded questions i want to make sure i
get to is
is teamwork online uh really the primary
avenue into professional sports jobs
particularly the nfl are there any
better suggestions
that's a loaded question i'm not sure
how to answer that one uh
i'd say a lot of it is right place right
time
i mean i was really fortunate i can only
i'll speak to my experiences
and again when i i think when anytime
you talk about your career
uh when you have certain breaks that
fall for you i certainly had a break
uh that went in my favor i was working
for stats
inc they've since been merged with
perform
and it's changed ownership a little bit
since i worked there roughly you know 10
12 years ago now but
i was working in an essentially a
startup group at stats
working with teams and the chicago bears
were a client of ours
and i developed a relationship through
that and next thing you know i found
myself sitting in a household
working for the bears and again i a lot
of that was luck being in the right
place at the right time i'd like to
think that you know my work had
uh you know certainly influenced it as
well but it was also there was a lot of
luck involved
so in terms of recommendations for
people to get started
uh you have this these unbelievable
platforms with social media to be able
to
show your work uh direct message people
that are involved in the field
uh linkedin twitter and so forth so be
able to just reach out
teamwork online is certainly one source
but there are others as well
thank you mitch um we have time for a
few more questions
here and i'll make sure to send the full
list of questions to you as well and
maybe we can go through and make sure
that we answer everything after as well
um but
another question is how were analytics
used for rapid in-game decisions
in your experience that was a big part
of my work when i was working for teams
was being able to
provide data-driven recommendations to
the coaching staff on the field or
that were also in the coaching booth
with me there are certain limitations
with the league rules
the league rules currently prohibit any
live data feeds
if that changes i would anticipate the
role of technology certainly changing
for teams because you now have access to
potential
calculators for wind probability and all
all sorts of things
there's certainly other ways to to do
that without
live data feeds but i think it requires
a little more creativity from the team
side of it
and there's also vendors that play in
that space that provide data-driven
recommendations with charts and tables
and
various data driven decision-making
tools
thank you so one let's see we have time
for one more question
is injury data available via the big
data bowl set
looking into games lost to injury i
don't know offhand
that's a i'm not sure if there's
somebody else on the chat that may want
to
chime in please do i'm not familiar
though if there is injury data
associated
with that do you
ask my i have a feeling you may know
more information on that
yeah i just saw mike lopez chime in so
thank you mike for attending and thanks
for
answering that question so again mike
lopez is from the nfl so
thank you mike mike thanks for joining
us as well but do you want to add
anything
to that on the big data bowl with that
no thanks
thanks mitch for the great overview and
um for
mentioning our event we certainly
encourage all folks
football fans not football fans to
participate in the big data bowl
um due mostly to sort of sensitivity
around the data we haven't included
injuries in the past
um i don't anticipate that changing the
future but we do welcome folks to
to get your hands wet um it's not just
good preparation for
uh you know work in football it's a
preparation for a career in really any
sports analytics we've had
uh recent big data well participants get
hired in
soccer in the nba and um it's just a
good way to get your hands messy with
tracking data
um because really that that's kind of
where all sports are going so
um yeah thanks if i can chime in there
too i would argue that if you can handle
the nfl's data the tracking data you're
going to be well prepared to handle data
in a lot of other industries because it
is a it's an extremely challenging data
set it requires some
technical chops to be able to interact
with it so again if you're just a
data enthusiast and you want to
challenge yourself i would really highly
encourage you to go grab that that
tracking data because it's
uh it's a really interesting data set
there's a lot of different applications
of that data
great and we'll have some more time for
questions at the end i just want to make
sure
that we get through megan's talk as well
she has a great talk on extending our
markdown
but also just a quick announcement um
from josh orenstein who's on from the
national basketball
association as well about some of the
nba's um
nba future stars program if you want to
let everyone know about that
yeah rachel thanks for having me uh my
name is josh ornstein and i'm a senior
data scientist
in the basketball strategy and analytics
department at the mba
and i'm really excited to be part of a
program that we're launching called
future analytics stars
uh we're launching in early august it's
a it's a career development program
uh targeted at potential interns and
early career applicants for analytics
roles
uh throughout the sport on the
basketball and on the
the business and the marketing side the
roughly it's it's going to be bi-weekly
like two-hour meetings
that's the general idea where we'll
feature real-world applications of
analytics
um and professional development
opportunities and mentorship
uh the program will culminate in a
capstone project that can be used as
part of your portfolio if you are
looking for a job
yeah the and like i said the goal here
is to is to help people
get placed into analytics roles um
applications are due
june 25th uh it's for us and canada
participates
participants only uh and i'll throw i'll
throw a link and my contact info into
the chat if you have any any further
questions
great thanks so much josh just want to
make sure everyone can hear me okay
right now my
headphone issue
you're good okay perfect thank you um
so with that i'd love to turn it over to
our second speaker
megan hall who will be presenting on
extending our markdown
from websites slides pdfs and more
so megan is a data scientist that
zealous analytics
is currently teaching a course on data
visualization at carnegie mellon
and so i know megan from twitter
and from the boston user group but she
contributes to the public sports
analytics community
by helping beginners learn more and also
by writing and presenting on
various aspects of hockey analysis as a
member of
hockey graphs and so with that i'll turn
it over to you megan
all right great all right i'm gonna
assume everyone can see my slides just
fine
um first of all uh thanks rachel for uh
such a nice intro
and thanks just kind of overall for
inviting me to speak it is a true honor
to speak about one of my
great loves our markdown especially at a
meet up on
r and sports analytics because
truthfully uh
most components of my career and to be
honest like my hobbies and my social
life
fit somewhere into the venn diagram of
those two things
in terms of the r side i am a data
manager and higher ed so i use our
you know every single day in our
markdown i'm also as rachel said i'm
currently teaching a dataviz course
at cmu that uses our rstudio
g2 plot our markdown of course
and then more on the sports side i am a
data scientist at zealous analytics
where i focus specifically on data
visualization and reporting in uh you
guessed it our markdown
and then also part of the uh decently
active member of the
public sports analytics community mostly
focusing on hockey and also creating
tutorials and resources for beginners or
people who are trying to
um get started with our through the lens
of sports analytics which i think is a
pretty nice way to kind of
usher yourself into the uh our ecosystem
um but today we're talking about our
markdown
which i think again we got mitch's great
talk kind of about overview of decision
making and sports analytics and i'm
going to talk about a particular
technical tool from our studio called
our markdown
i think it's really useful to tackle um
some of the specific things that mitch
talked about
so our markdown is at least in my mind a
really powerful and undervalued tool
for a really powerful and undervalued
component of data science
uh which is communication um we all know
or most of us probably know that
the tidy burst and all of its related
packages make
the analysis side of data science much
easier
and i'm hoping today to convince you if
you're not already convinced that our
markdown and all of its associated
packages
do kind of the same thing in making the
communication
piece of data science much easier
similar to the way that again tightly
verse does
to the technical side because i
personally think that a lot of data
science education
falls a little bit short in terms of
really emphasizing the
communication piece which again is a
really essential
piece of your kind of general analysis
pipeline workflow whatever because
without this communication piece
your analysis can kind of exist in a
silo and of course
no one wants that and this communication
can mean
communicating with yourself probably all
of us have had
the experience of opening a you know our
script or you know whatever language you
work in from like six months ago
and you're like well i wish i had
commented that better and you don't
remember kind of the decisions that you
made
so focusing on communicating with
yourself clearly uh
first of all is super important can
really save time
and also true to if you're talking about
communicating with your teammates isn't
like immediate people
who you work closely with on the same
projects being able to really clearly
document again your decision making
process
why you chose these certain elements
maybe why you chose this model why you
chose to visualize this data in a
certain way
communicating all that and again adding
all the extra context that might be
missing from just kind of a standard
r script um can again make it so much
easier for your teammates if they ever
need to reproduce or build off of your
work
and again kind of most importantly um
communicating to people who are above
you on the organizational ladder
because sometimes uh or excuse me most
of the time the person that is doing
the analysis is not the person who is
actually responsible for making the
decisions based on those results
sometimes you know it is depending on
like your role and what organization you
work for
but generally there are at least a
couple layers of people in between
like in sports for example the person
who if you're you know working in sports
analytics for a company or a team
all the great analysis you're doing you
are probably not the one who is making
decisions on player acquisitions or
roster construction or game time
decisions
etc etc and so being able to
adequately explain your results to
different layers of people
again if you were explaining to someone
to a teammate your analysis
would not include the same kind of
details and context as if you were
explaining that
to an assistant coach for example which
um
ties perfectly into something that mitch
said we did not even coordinate this but
i was so happy when i saw this on one of
his slides i even wrote down
if you can't clearly explain your work
don't expect a decision maker to buy in
and use it
which is really so true and it is a true
essential skill to be able to
again distill your analysis and either
apply or remove
context and technical details based on
the audience that you're
trying to present to because without
again if you can't convince
say your coach on the results of you
know your analysis on timeouts
then your analysis is basically
pointless most of us are doing this work
in order to you know provide the data
behind these
data driven decisions and hopefully make
change
now we can't um as i said this is a
really essential
skill to have unfortunately we can't go
super in depth into how to develop that
skill because i was only given
uh 10 minutes for this talk and i'm not
a magician but
i'm hoping to convince you again today
that our markdown is a really useful
tool
to use that skill
so many of us are probably you've either
been at this stage of a workflow
or you know someone who's in the stage
or hopefully maybe you've helped someone
who's in the stage
who's using excel for their data
analysis
i mean i'm never someone who uh
i guess kind of who poo poos like excel
like excel is a great tool
and being proficient in excel and using
it proficiently is a really essential
skill i would think for a lot of data
analysis roles particularly if you work
closely
with people who might use excel for you
know again certain appropriate
business cases and might have less
technical roles than you do
but a lot of a lot of people do take
kind of the capabilities of excel
a little too far when i think they could
really be better served by using a tool
like r tidy verse all of its associated
packages etc
for you know making their data the
technical side of their data analysis
work
more reproducible so hopefully
again people move to this next step
which is an amazing step
again just taking the data analysis and
making that more reproducible
using our is amazing i personally stayed
at this step
for a very long time and again this is
miles of
this mile's better than uh this first
step i showed
but i think some people can stay in this
step too long as i said i did
where i had really was really pleased
with all the efficiency gains i got in
moving
my analysis work into r but i was still
handling kind of all the data
communication pieces
by kind of keeping all my documentation
and word
documents and creating all my slide
decks to you know
convey the results of my analyses to you
know various higher up audiences
in powerpoint and so what i'm hoping to
convince people
is actually the ideal workflow is to
substitute
our markdown for all these kind of data
science communication
names because there are so many output
formats different
that are possible with our markdown and
keeping everything in the same universe
in the same ecosystem will kind of
streamline the communication side
of your data science work just like
using our tidy words etc really
streamlines the analysis part
of your data analysis work so we talked
about
how you know you can you need to
communicate at different levels
and many of you might be familiar with
kind of what i call like a classic our
markdown
document which doesn't take any kind of
special package it outputs an html file
these can be really useful again to
yourself and your teammates
as they really easily incorporate code
and plot
and text generally text that's more fl
it's more fleshed out than just you know
short comments in our script
um this example is actually a lab
assignment from my course but it's a
good example of how you can very easily
combine text and code
and plots into a simple html file that's
again very easy to share and it really
makes you focus
on reproducibility i make my students
use our markdown
because part of the class is learning
about how to get used to a reproducible
data science workflow
and if i cannot you know reproduce your
html file on
my computer you lose points um what you
know in the real world means your work
is not as reproducible
um so that is a great step and then also
in terms when you need to
you know start presenting to some layers
of people above you
like the if you if we stick to our
example of you have all of your
work that you did on on analyzing like
the values of timeouts and your
you know nfl coach wants this data
you're not going to send him hopefully
maybe there are some coaches out there
who would appreciate it but you're
probably not going to send him like your
really long
standard our markdown file that has all
of your different code decisions in your
plots like that's too much information
but thankfully our markdown has lots of
other options you can create
dashboards with flex dashboards you can
create slides with sharingan
these slides i've created today are
created again with our markdown with
sharon again
these particular slides are pre-played
because this talk is pretty short and
mostly
talking about theoretical things and not
necessarily showing codes and plots
but it's really easily really easy to
again incorporate code
and or plots and of course all the you
know images and other formatting things
that you would expect to have
from presentations but we can move away
from the land of having to screenshot
all of your plots and then pull those
into your powerpoint by instead in our
markdown you can just refer to chunks
that code chunks kind of be our markdown
verbiage you can refer
to chunks that already exist and again
much easier so you don't have to worry
about when you make a change either you
get new data or you make
maybe a change in your model you don't
have to worry about updating again all
these
screenshot plots in your slides
and then lastly um might be more on kind
of a personal if you ever want to
communicate
to the public again there are lots of
our markdown
driven packages that do that a book down
makes it very easy to create
like online books uh most of the
kind of online books you've seen online
the popular ones about our related
topics most of those were built with
book down
there are also several different are
bark down driven packages for website
development
distill is a very popular package
i personally have my course website that
i created with distill and actually as i
mentioned
everything about my course is completely
created in our markdown from
my lecture slides to again assignments
etc
and then there's another popular our
markdown driven package called blog down
that i personally use for my personal
website
and again these these types of packages
again for website development
being our markdown driven means you
build them with our markdown documents
build them in our studio
and even we're getting a little meta
here but the blog posts themselves like
this
one i just chose as an example is also
driven by our markdown so again it's
super easy to combine text and
code which is easy for someone to copy
which is helpful for education purposes
as well as of course plots and there are
again
several other even categories that we
didn't get into today there are special
packages
um for creating journal articles there
are packages for creating
interactive tutorials like hosted again
through html online
which is super useful if like anything
about your job involves any kind of
education component
so i just kind of you know spit off the
name of like half a dozen packages
and you're probably like oh my god
there's so many different packages to
learn
but kind of one of the bright sides is
just like how
if you kind of learn the basic syntax of
the tidy verse
is that kind of allows you to easily
extend that into other related packages
like tidy models and ggplot the exact
same is true for our markdown
once and i would argue it's even
actually much easier once you have the
basic syntax of our markdown again as i
mentioned
um you can create things in chunks and
there's various options as to what you
can do if you want to show or hide
code or plots etc and once you're
familiar with kind of the basic syntax
of our markdown
that means it's very easy to all you
have to do is again learn kind of the
specific details about the various
output formats in the packages
but it's really much very easy to just
take whatever your analysis work is
and easily make that into different
output formats whether that's an html
file you want to share with a teammate
or you know a set of slides to make a
presentation to show to someone higher
up which of course wouldn't have code
but would probably have some plots that
you know resulted from that code and so
you don't have to duplicate
that work um so i hope again
it was difficult to distill all of my
love for our mark down into
10-ish minutes but i hope that you are
either inspired to
include our markdown to start including
our markdown as a part of your workflow
or if we are if you already use our
markdown a little bit like maybe you
work
you kind of do your personal analysis in
our markdown documents which is a great
start
is that you realize kind of how much
knowledge you already have and you can
really easily extend those capabilities
into other formats and create slides and
websites etc
and so i've included a few links here uh
these
are these slides will be posted by the
way on my website and my twitter
this first link here is just a basic our
markdown tutorial on the rstudio website
um which is really great for just again
learning the basic
output formats and capabilities of our
markdown
and i've also linked here to the
definitive guide of our markdown
which is an online book of course
created with book down
that again goes into lots of details on
all the various output formats
and then lastly allison works for
rstudio and
is in my mind at least the queen of r
markdown and has produced
so much great content on so many
different aspects of
our markdown so i have a link to the
project page on her website so if you
have a question about our markdown
or again how to learn blog down or
distill etc
she probably has some content on it
so again i hope this has inspired you to
incorporate some more
our mark down into your life and i wish
you luck
on that journey um and before i leave i
just wanted to mention since we have
such a great
collection of people here who are
interested in are interested in sport
in sports analytics um i definitely want
to mention uh that does company that i
work for that is an industry leader in
the sports analytics space
is about to be hiring in several
different roles we're going to be hiring
for
uh data scientists and data engineers
and analytics engineers
both at junior and senior levels
it's a really fun really smart team
that's doing a lot of cool work across
multiple sports
so i really recommend that you either
apply if you are interested
or just kind of spread the word we're
hoping to get a nice big candidate pool
those job descriptions will hopefully
be posted by the end of the week and
they will be on again the zealous
website and zell's twitter and hopefully
they'll just be kind of be floating
around
sports analytics twitter if that is a
place where you hang out
thanks again rachel in our studio and
everyone for having me
thank you so much megan um
if you have questions for megan if you
wouldn't mind when you put them into
slido to put
megan's name as well just so it's a
little bit easier to sort through them
and i think there may be have been a few
questions in the chat on zoom
if you could copy those over as well
will make it easier to
sort through
thank you and and one question that was
just shared megan is can you collect
user data via blog down
oh that's a good question i actually
don't know um i would have to look into
it i
um i put my personal website i don't i
don't have any
uh tracking like i don't have any
tracking data or
you know uh data on who visits my
website but i assume there are probably
options it might depend on who you host
your website through
thank you megan and um
next time i will definitely have someone
help me with moderating
business so i mean sorry moderating the
slido so if there's any questions for
megan that i've missed
feel free to just say them out loud as
well um
but something i wanted to ask you about
megan is i know you commented
um when people are asking about how to
potentially be hired by a sports team
and you said
like putting your work out there and
having public work would you be able to
speak a little bit more
yeah um i it's certainly not the only
avenue to work in sports and whether
that's working for a team
or working for some kind of associated
company like the company i work for is a
consulting company basically that's
hired by teams in various sports
um so as kind of mitch was mentioning it
does certainly depend on luck for most
sports related jobs there tend to be a
lot more qualified applicants than
positions available just because it
tends to be a popular industry
um so there are certainly people who
just get hired either straight out of
school or because you apply
um but a lot of people also at least get
on people's radar
because of public work that they have so
becoming involved
in really any way in the um public
sports analytics community again whether
that's you know in one sport or in
multiple sports
there is some kind of data out there for
at least most of the major sports you
know the quality and kind of quantity of
that data can vary
by sport but people know of obviously if
someone is hiring from within a sport
that doesn't have a lot of
public data they like they're aware
that's a restriction um so just kind of
again
using it um just exploring
same as what mitch said just kind of
doing it and it's a great way to learn r
also if you are a beginner is just
asking figuring some kind of question
you have and finding the data and like
learning as much as you need
to know about are to answer that
question so having some kind of
portfolio of public data and some kind
of easily available
place again whether that's github or a
super basic website
um is again really helpful
because i can tell you even from again
we're about to start hiring at zealous
and i know a lot of people have you know
internal the company just have lists of
people that they're
aware of in the analytics community just
by
you know work that they present so
getting involved in that and
really presenting any of your work
having some kind of public record of the
work you can do
um is always useful
that's a great point and i had i see two
other questions for you
one is how do you think hockey stats
compare to other sports for analytics
is it easier to use or more definitive
results
larger smaller sample sizes
um i think it depends on on the type of
data that you have access to
the public data for hockey is nice in
that it is consistently available but it
is not super particularly
detailed i mean in saying that i think
there are still there are plenty of
insights that have been gained from the
data that is publicly available and i
would argue there
probably still are insights that can be
gained from that data
but probably a lot of the kind of
cutting edge again more of the tracking
data we know that exists for hockey but
it's not publicly available at the
moment
so probably most of the again more
cutting edge advanced techniques are
coming from again data that's still
internal
um but i do think there is a decent
amount of data available for hockey at
least in terms of the
nhl it does very well wildly as you move
into
either women's hockey or other leagues
junior leagues
et cetera but i do think there is a
decent amount of
public data for hockey thank you
and last question is do you have any
recommendations as to
where to host them are marked on the
site
yes so everything that i have hosted
again i have i have two websites one
that's built through distill and one
that's built through blog down
both of those are hosted through netlify
which is a pretty common workflow for
hosting these
markdown sites because it connects super
easily with github so if you just have a
github repo
for your site it connects and it's free
um i do have
again my course website has this
netlify.app at the end you can of course
pay for a custom domain name i don't
really care for a course website so i
have this
but if you're just a personal r user and
you
like use your website for our related
purposes
you can get a for free again you can
just google it you can get an rbine.io
um address which you'll see pretty
common so this is you know a little more
custom just with my name but this is
also free but this is meant to be for
people who are
you know have you have some kind of blog
you're doing tutorials and you know
again trying to share our knowledge
thank you so much megan and thank you
mitch for your presentation as well
i know there are quite a few questions
that are on slido that may have gone
unanswered in the time we had today so
i'll be sure to share
all the questions and take them from the
zoom chat to
share with the speakers to get answers
for you
so much mitch um and thank you megan for
your presentations
have a good day everyone thank you